to give a gift like the cast of lectures
it takes generosity of a special kind
brick-and-mortar I have a long half-life
lectures shorter the value of a building
is evident immediately but lectures at
any rate so far as they're about ideas
their value even value generously
defined requires faith and as it happens
faith is what I'm going to be talking
about although it's faced of a quite
particular kind and it's as I've dubbed
it the democratic face all in all I'm
going to make the claim that citizens
are better at reasoning about politics
and have better reasons for the choices
that they make that's been recognized
and and maybe the best way to make plain
what I'm aiming at is to begin at the
beginning
the beginning of my career as a
researcher
I joined it was it was it was at the
invitation of my mentor a project and
the project was funded if I recall that
close to a million dollars that's 1970
dollars and I thought this was like big
machine physics and and so I joined but
but I joined out of ambition not out of
any interest and the problem itself
which was social indicators I thought it
was the way to make my career well it
was the worst decision I've made
professionally and we went along working
on the project and as the project went
along I got more and more agitated doing
something that I didn't I didn't believe
in and and I'd start waking up at 2
o'clock 3 o'clock in the morning and
walk downstairs to the library from my
bedroom and and read for a half an hour
to an hour not not because I was
interested in just just read long enough
so that I could get tired and go back to
bed and I gosh I do remember I remember
the night I woke up I went downstairs
and and I'm and my hand fell on a book
on a shelf it was the Federalist Papers
and I took them out and I just started
to read just just so that I could get
tired again and I read through sitting
on sofa and I read through a couple and
and then I stopped
and I said okay suppose you've been
reading him back then what would you
said would you have decided and I knew I
mean I knew instantly what I would have
said had I been there then I would have
said this this is a noble idea but it it
doesn't have a prayer people just aren't
up to this and right then I knew that I
was capable of a world historical
mistake I would have bet against the
best political idea there's ever been
and all that I've been trying to do
since is to try and figure out what I
didn't understand what is it that I
didn't appreciate about citizens that
would have led me to sell them so short
and and that they fall short that is
that is broadly the accepted view it
certainly it's the accepted view in
systematic studies of public opinion and
voting democracy works on the evidence
so far as it works in spite of and not
because of citizens voters in study
after study has shown that they have
minimal levels of knowledge about public
affairs they paid minimal amount of
attention to them they make their
choices
rooted in habit or the choices or
products of considerations that happen
more or less by chance to be salient at
the moment people are choosing they are
we are so far as their citizens
empty-headed that's the problem non
attitude so we're muddle-headed that's
the problem lack of constraint now one
alternative when is to take a look at uh
at research and and just challenge it
just challenge the validity of it and
and and and and and and and there are
points on which I think that previous
research some points is exaggerated or
just wrong but it just seems to me to be
a habit that undermines accumulation of
knowledge to look at three or four
decades of the best in research and
simply declare that it's wrong that the
conventional wisdom is wrong so I want
to start by accepting the validity of
previous research what I want to claim
though is that it's valid but it's
one-sided and I want to I want to take
up that claim in an area that I think
goes to the meaning of the American
experience and that's racism and how
Americans deal with race
previous research it's concentrated on
the weaknesses of citizens
and what I want to do is to point to
some of their strengths and that's the
theme that's going to run through these
lectures but this one this one is on the
the problem that I started with first
and they've stayed with longest and
that's race and and that's the reason
for the title of the talk today mere
adolfs conjecture
now Afghan Emir Dahl was once a name
everyone knew and they knew it because
it was equated with a transformative
idea that's those are words that almost
everybody read 40 years ago the American
dilemma is the ever raging conflict
between on the one hand the valuations
preserved on the general plane which we
shall call the American creed and on the
other hand evaluations on specific
planes of individual and group living or
personal and local interests economic
social and sexual jealousies
considerations of community prestige in
conformity group prejudice against
particular persons who types of persons
and all sorts of miscellaneous wants
impulses and habits dominate his outlook
neared all bet on the American creed he
understood the American creed to consist
of commitment to liberty equality and
fair play and he believed in the
propulsive force of those moral ideals
and America did undergo as he had hoped
transformation that culminated in Civil
Rights Act of 1964 and the Voting Rights
Act of 1965 and you would have supposed
that that would have been a triumphant
vindication of mere doll success on a
scale unimaginable only a few years
earlier but painfully just a few years
later mere doll was stripped of his
reputation as an expert on race
relations in America the riots of the
60s the eruption of black power above
all the realization of the scale of the
barriers to racial equality made his
ideas seem utopian vision and political
scientists studying race consigned the
American creed to a more naive past and
concentrated energies on prejudice on
demonstrating its power on demonstrating
its persistence what do I mean by
prejudice here's a list of definitions
that I called from the classic social
psychology textbooks they differ in some
detail for some element that's
dispositive is stereotyping for others
its rigidity but it but if you run your
eye down it and you look at the failure
of human heartedness and pattern
hostility and hostility and regression
more hostility more unfavorable that is
I think the key to the meaning of
prejudice it is a persisting predictable
systemic readiness to belittle to
dislike to punish to push away members
of a minority by virtue of their being
members of a minority the more
derogatory hostile aversive person is to
a minority more prejudiced he or she is
that is just what I mean by prejudiced
and 25 years gosh it is 25 years ago I
on a number of other colleagues tried to
translate that conception into a set of
operations for measuring prejudice in
general population survey and so we
developed this measure and here's a few
words about that some that people
sometimes used to describe blacks no
words right about everybody how well
does each of these words describe most
blacks most blacks and then there are 14
adjectives nine of the adjectives are
positive five or negative the purpose of
the positive adjectives was to give an
opportunity to respondents to say
something nice so that we could free
them up to say something nasty that
that's what they were there for they
were and what's the term cheap talk
they were meaningless prejudice consists
of readiness to systematically respond
mercifully to a minority our measure of
prejudice was the five negative
adjectives the more of the adjectives
you said described blocks well and the
better the description you said they
gave up blacks the more prejudiced you
were
and that that measure we have evaluated
against all the other measures that have
been in use and and it has gone through
a process a really rigorous construct
validation and we've used it in study
after study and in country after country
about well we with one change since
every its it cost money to ask the
question and it's in an interview yeah
that's what Survey Research is it's it's
about time and spending money for time
and after after the first study that we
did this since what I was interested in
is measuring prejudice I decided I just
wasn't going to waste money on nine
questions when they weren't actually
doing any work I would just take one of
the positive adjectives to start off the
series and then get right to the heart
of the matter and assess people's
willingness to respond negatively to a
minority group and that's and that and
then that's what we did for for fifteen
years but but I found that that the
studies that I was doing gradually
especially the ones in Western Europe in
welfare states that that without without
really my being consciously aware of it
until relatively recently that Mira
dolls ideas were pushing themselves back
into my mind now I didn't think that
that his formulation was right that that
that I'm I didn't think then and I don't
think now
Mira saw the conflict as going on in the
hearts and minds of white Americans now
there are circumstances in which people
can find themselves will find themselves
torn about what they want to do on
issues of race but for mass politics the
evidence really is decisive there there
just aren't many white Americans are
torn my inner conflicts over race the
conflict is inter not intra personal
okay so if so in what sense can mere
dolls conjecture be right here's the
standard way that that we think about
prejudice it's the way that's consistent
with all those definitions that were
enumerated they think about that that
line as though it's it's like a pressure
gauge and you know you can measure
pressures as being high medium low just
the same way the idea is that you're
going to rank order people from along
you know from most prejudice to somewhat
less prejudice less prejudice still to
not prejudiced but that's as good as it
gets is the absence of ill-will
and that is what started nagging at me
whether that is in fact the best that it
gets here's an alternative way of
thinking about it think about it as
though there's an effective evaluative
continuum and you can rank order people
from those who are most negative in
their feelings towards blacks less less
less indifferent or ambivalent and those
who are more positive somewhat positive
and those who are more positive still
now that conception is is radically
different from the first what it does is
to illuminate a possibility that some in
a majority group do not just not think
ill of a minority but think well of them
and want things to go well for them and
this conception of a effective continuum
that runs from most negative to most
positive it has the great virtue of
modesty it imposes the fewest and the
most transparent assumptions all you
have to do is to presume there's a
continuum that there are two poles
negative and positive and that the
differences are monotonic not linear
that is there's no presumption that that
being most positive is as positive as
being most negative is negative
and and and I and I and and that is the
way that that I because of the modesty
of the assumptions have found it useful
to think about it in the in the in the
book you're kind enough to advertise
that's forthcoming the book on the
cartoon crisis and and there and there
we try and and and make a case for a
concept of inclusive tolerance all the
same I'm I guess I'm I think that that's
not an acceptable way station I think
it's necessary to go farther here is a
representation where you think of
positive and negative feelings they're
not on the same continuum or dimension
they form two dimensions there's not one
set of feelings there to negative and
positive
okay that that is formally what the
claim is that there that there are two
dimensions and the dimensions are
orthogonal at right angles to each other
and that is what the analysis the
empirical analysis the factor analysis
exploratory and confirmatory will yield
there's two independent factors but the
crux of the matter is that those two
factors though orthogonal will be
empirically correlated they will be
highly correlated and that's because a
person who has very positive feelings
about blacks is unlikely to have very
negative feelings and vice-versa so so
here you have somebody who scores high
on positive effect and low on negative
here you got somebody who is kind if I
could do that is low on positive and
moderate on negative and here you've got
somebody in between and if you plotted
the positions of respondents over those
two dimensions you'd find a cloud of
points that are thickly packed along a
common line so measures of positive and
negative affect are correlated depending
on a study anywhere between 0.45 and
point five oh okay so why is that
important
it's actually it's pivotal
because it just so far as it's true it
raises the possibility that part of what
has appeared to be the impact of
prejudice on the political thinking of
white Americans may be a result of
failing to take account of the fact that
some whites have positive feelings about
blacks that the two measures are highly
albeit negatively inter correlated now
once I realized that that was a
possibility I dawned on me that all
along 25 years ago we had had in our
hands the ability to test them because
those measures that I showed you I had
nine positive adjectives to work with I
had just assumed that they were
meaningless I had assumed that people if
they said something favourable bought
blocks that it was no more than social
manners but then went to work and
analyzed raised a new data set we
administered the the items underwent a
nun undertook a variety of factor
analyses and lo and behold there are two
dimensions one positive and one negative
now there's a standard method and I've
said it's factor analysis for defining
the dimensionality of a space but it's
merely empirical I mean it's just like
saying to the Machine go to work and go
find me some factories oops I think I
know what the factors are I'll tell you
the criteria go look for them
but it's just an empirical result if
you're measuring two different things
then there should be respects in which
they differ one measures should be
correlated with a set of variables that
the other is not correlated with this
measure should be correlated with a set
of variables that this measure is not
correlated with so so what should that
be in this case well it's it is it's not
terribly hard to figure out a set of
expectations for a measure of negative
feelings towards blacks anything that
measures mean-spiritedness a general
punitive nough Stennis e2 hostility
towards others and and and for that
matter towards other minority groups
those should be distinctively correlated
with a measure of negative effect
towards blacks question though is what
should a measure of positive effect
towards blacks be correlated with
distinctively correlated with and that's
where I think that mere doll really
provides the vital clue
it's the sentiments of a fair play and
equality
you know understood as giving everyone
the opportunity to succeed the readiness
to respond sympathetically and nurturing
to others who are less fortunate to wish
to see that everyone has at the least
what they need
is it the case that notwithstanding the
fact that these two measures are so
highly intercourse study it's something
on the order of 0.47 are they
nonetheless distinctively correlated
with criterion variables here's a test
for dislike of blacks if you look at the
first row you're going to see that their
coefficient for this in this case is the
each of the variables running down on
the left hand side have been regressed
on our two measures of negative effect
and positive effect and readiness to say
that people tend to make excuses for
failure is correlated with negative
effect at 0.25 3 and with positive
effect towards blacks 0 and the pattern
is the same for a readiness that
distrust those who are different for a
belief that societies too soft on the
undeserving for a propensity to believe
that the unsuccessful people are
unsuccessful have only themselves to
blame and consistent with all studies
done to prejudice since the
authoritarian personality negative
effect is uniquely correlated with
anti-semitism and and and and and a
measure which which astonishingly people
haven't caught on to its psychological
tolerance it was developed by Harrison
Gulf the leading psychometrician of his
generation and it was developed to
measure anti-semitism but it is pure
criterion validity there is no reference
at all in any of the items that make up
this measure to Jews or to any other
minority group
a sample item is most people are honest
chiefly through fear of getting caught
so so there's no you're not engaging any
desire to evade social censure and to
appear to be tolerant and inclusive
because the items don't refer to any
group minority or majority for that
matter and at zero zero zero all the
well almost zero all the way down for
positive effect but is the obverse the
case yes here are set of items that were
written with Mira dolls depiction of the
American creed in mind and it's unequal
chances in life or a real big problem
the needy deserve help should help the
less fortunate and more equal wealth
would reduce problems and and regressing
each of those on our measures of
negative and positive effect gives you
exactly the opposite pattern
coefficients that matter on there in the
right column coefficients that go to
zero on the left so there's not just a
factorial separation between negative
effect and positive effect they're
measuring different things and insofar
as they're measuring different things
they themselves are different politics
the key question is whether or not it
matters if people think well of blocks
it's not like it has to matter we've got
all kinds of research that suggests that
under some circumstances people fake
good but even if they're not faking it
is not obvious that it will carry over
and influence their choices and in any
horse race between the power of ill will
and the power good will I'm not sure
that I could find anybody that'd be
willing to bet even a good odds on the
power of goodwill so here are a series
of tests whenever possible we take items
as they've been developed by others when
they're not integral to what we're doing
original so that that everybody else can
feel comfortable that they know the
behavior of the items that we're
analyzing these this is an item from the
American National Election studies
should government help blacks or should
they help themselves and it's regressed
on our measure of negative effect
dislike of blacks and as you can see
there's this is a sample from 2012 and
just white Americans and a sample got
gathered and interviewed by YouGov so
it's a nifty it's nifty in magnitude
what happens though if you put alongside
it measure of goodwill towards blacks
yes the coefficient for positive effect
is larger than the coefficient for
negative effect but but I wouldn't ask
you to put any emphasis on that at all
everything that we measure no matter how
many decimal points that has how many
asterisk is done at a level of Cruden's
so it's consistency that counts
here's another standard item from the
American national election studies
government is sure fair treatment for
blacks and jobs again a very substantial
coefficient again we now ask whether or
not goodwill matters to again goodwill
matters at least as much as ill-will
here's a item on affirmative action and
again at least as much although notice
that the coefficients are noticeably
smaller and that's because there's just
a lot less variance to in White's
attitudes towards affirmative action and
a final illustration should government
assure equal opportunity for blacks
again substantial impact of prejudice
but that impact
this is always shrinking when you take
account of positive feelings towards
blocks prejudice is always less
important and usually markedly less
important once you also take account of
positive feelings towards blacks one
last piece of evidence
here's combined measure of our
individual items on racial liberalism
and then to try and be clear about this
we took advantage of a measure of a
propensity to inhibit the expression to
wish to inhibit the expression of
negative sentiments towards the minority
group developed by Elizabeth I was
flopped and then her colleagues and it
doesn't cut in to any degree to the
impact of a positive effect it's not
that Express goodwill appears to be
important because people wish merely to
convey a socially desirable image of
themselves conclusion okay Mira doll he
believed in the propulsive power of
moral ideals and it was just this that
opened him up to ridicule and ridicule
it was is that masterwork in American
dilemma was dismissed in a in a stinging
phrase that made the rounds as sunshine
sociology
which wasn't which was a which was a
pity because it it wasn't just that mere
dog got it right it was that that whole
idea of of a of an American creed of a
belief in equality and liberty and fair
play
that was his device to rally white
Americans to the cause of racial
equality as it happened the whole idea
of an American creed only came to mere
doll in Sweden during the Second World
War
when as he saw the Swedish government
targets for lock whenever Nazis wanted
some favor he aiming to try and rally
his fellow Swedes to the consciousness
of liberty that's when he and his wife
came up with the idea of the American
creed well I don't as I say believed
that the that the precise formulation
was correct there are no studies that
I'm aware of which show that substantial
numbers of white Americans are torn by
psychological conflicts over race but
what he got but what he got right that
that went deeper research on on the
beliefs and acts of white Americans on
the issue of racism has for 40 years
concentrated entirely on prejudice on
its persistence and its power and that
work has not been wrong but it has been
one-sided and and the one-sided focus on
ill-will has obscured the fact that
there is goodwill
I don't I don't want to exaggerate the
power of goodwill it's not a primary
factor in the politics of race but I
guess I want to insist that mayor Dahl
had a deep insight pointed to it and
that the claim no of colleagues whose
work I value that racism now has as
powerful a grip on thinking of white
Americans as it did 50 years ago is a
fallacy actually it's a product of a
mitad variable bias and it's a result of
a failure to experiment with the idea
that goodwill
as well as ill-will can be forced in
politics questions
yeah I'll make sure I'll make sure to be
loud and hear you so yeah great
so I think it's a it's a novel and I
think really appealing idea to split
goodwill and ill-will into two separate
variables but what and I haven't looked
at your data you know closely but would
it be sort of a methodological problem
if you know you asked to measure
goodwill a question that said we should
increase aid to you know black families
and it was strongly correlated with
goodwill and had very little correlation
with Elmo but then you asked a question
that said we should not increase aid to
black families and it was not correlated
with goodwill but was correlated with it
well well that would that display sort
of an rationality in the minds of voters
and that they don't necessarily see one
policy as the you know flip side or the
other they don't see the connection
between the position of increasing aid
and not giving worried no no no I got
there's a methodological question that's
a substantive question the
methodological question thank the
American national election studies for
resolving it used to be the case in the
early studies that policy items were
asked agree disagree and it turned out
that in that format people's attitudes
were unstable and positions that they
took on different issues didn't go
together to the degree that they should
that one would expect that they do and
the problem was that they weren't being
presented with alternatives to choose
among so that they could see what the
universe of
looked like and in 1972 actually with a
colleague Richard Brodie they introduced
national exercises introduced these
seven point dual alternative formats
okay so so that's you know the
measurement answer the substantive
answer I think is the issue goes deeper
what one can think of any of a number of
policies that have been put forward to
to help blacks there should be more
government spending on jobs programs
there should be more aid to families
with dependent children there should be
and and then we got there should be
affirmative action in varying degrees
and forms and and then almost
immediately people researchers observed
that while the largest number of white
Americans accepted racial equality at
the as an abstract principle there was a
sharp divide over these policies and the
interpretation that was put on that it's
called the principal policy puzzle was
that while they said they believed in
equality at the level of principle when
they were actually being asked to put it
into practice they balked which showed
that they really didn't believe in the
principle
so it was sociologists actually that
introduced that formulation and and now
and and and an oddly political
scientists didn't catch on to it because
actually what what what we were doing
was is here's a number of policies that
are liberal policies do you support them
and and and liberals tended to support
them and conservatives overwhelmingly
reject them and and that is the great
divide over race it's this deep
ideological divide it's not just about
race so race adds its own little extra
component but American politics has been
defined by a a great ideological
cleavage in the electorate over what the
role of government should be and and to
an extent that that I find even now hard
to to understand the presumption has
been that somehow prejudice has been
this force that set loose whereas I mean
America has just been having this battle
between left and right it's not that
prejudice doesn't matter it does matter
but it doesn't come anywhere close to to
ideology especially about social welfare
issues where people do have coherent
views and capturing what's at stake and
why people divide as they divide
oh gosh I wish I could tell you I repeat
exactly the same items that we developed
25 years ago but I changed the response
format known and I changed it because I
for reasons that seemed to me to be
compelling but I understood at the time
that there was going to be this cost I
will tell you the thing that strikes me
the most about all measures that have to
do with race is their stability over
time there there just isn't it used to
be the case that when it came to
tolerance that every cohort entering the
electorate would be a little bit more
tolerant than the one before it and even
though the difference was fairly small
if you accumulate as you accumulate over
cohorts it gets to be a very substantial
difference and but I don't feel
confident that I can tell you that that
that process is kept on going for racial
tolerance if it has we don't have
instruments that are sufficiently
reliable to give me confidence to say
that yeah
you're thinking how you're thinking
about those indicators change what
exactly
it began with a study in the Netherlands
and and in it and it's it seemed to me
as an American that that I was catching
sight of a more a stronger desire on the
part of some parts of Dutch society to
help immigrants become part of Dutch
society to have jobs to get good
education to succeed and and then with
the Danish study it became even more so
and and and the reason I think that it
was easier to see that there was that
they don't have the same ideological
divide over the welfare state yes there
are conservative parties like but but
the idea is not that they're going to
eliminate the welfare state they're just
going to make it more efficient we're
gonna make it work a little bit better
and so you don't have the same problem
of if somebody is politically
conservative balking at a policy not
necessarily because they dislike a
minority group but because they don't
like the policy and so I got persuaded a
bit that that there there might in
liberal democracies be a stronger Reynes
in the part of some to to think well of
and to want things to go well for groups
that are less fortunate and that's when
I decided I'd actually give it a try
and see if that were so and did it first
with the first election for Obama and
found that that the measure the positive
measure wasn't as consequential as the
negative but you know sort of in the
same neighborhood and then as I went
along and saw what I saw in the Danish
study was just astonished me I mean I
really was taken away by the find he
said my colleagues there then I decided
I'd give it a try and I suppose you
could say that that I thought I got
lucky and because the expression is
trial and error right you try something
and he usually turns out to be wrong
it's not trial and success but but this
time it worked out not so badly yeah
so positive and negative feelings are
are inversely correlated so that someone
who's course high on one measure will
tend to score low on the other but there
are a substantial number of people that
who you can locate on a continuum as
either having about an equal number of
positive and negative scores or very low
scores on both and the second would
point to indifference and the first
ambivalence and ambivalence has always
been a live hypothesis and and and and
for a while there was reason to believe
in some studies that that the most
generous response on social welfare
issues came from people who while they
did feel positively towards blacks also
disliked blacks on some scores and and
that conflict of feelings amplified the
generosity of their response and and
that and that was a you know as a
intellectually of a very reasonable
proposition and empirically there was
some evidence for it
but despite the most diligent search in
any data set I can put my hands on I
can't find anything that suggests that
even people who have any degree of
positive and negative are are stand out
for the amplitude of their response it
was it was a good idea it could have
been true certainly it's an idea that's
true under some circumstances you can
put people in situations that can create
that ambivalence
but dispositional ii people tend to
consistency and and then there's an even
better theory and even more research on
why that's true because inconsistency is
painful that's the whole point about
cognitive dissonance so III thought that
that was a good possibility but but
empirically it just doesn't turn out to
be very productive yes today there's no
experiments
I've done the same analyses on a series
of experiments that we've done because
it always the idea that's that that
you're not hearing what people you know
the people don't mean quite what they
say is something that you should never
put away from your mind when you're
analyzing data like this
and and so I've gone through and look I
reserve the right to change my mind you
know if I if I find something but but I
but I just can't I haven't been able to
so far and and and but but I did include
the anti-racism measure just so to have
a response here my view is that this is
such a simple idea that when you present
the evidence for it you'd present it you
should present it in the most
transparent way you can in the simplest
way that it's possible because
and because I as I'd look back it's I I
don't understand why I didn't think of
it before we've just never entered my
head in all those years of measuring
prejudice that I might to some degree
also be having a met have developed a
measure that was capturing just the
opposite to some degree and so now when
I want to show why I believe that you
one should think take this possibility
up seriously I really do want to present
it in the simplest possible way and okay
so and there's there's the last thing
and I think that it's it's it's it's
it's what I owe my teacher there is
among social scientists I'm persuaded
just a fundamental misunderstanding of
the nature of prejudice when I was a
graduate student I took a course with
her at McCloskey and the purpose of that
course was to design a survey and and my
assignment was to develop a measure of
subtle prejudice I worked and came came
that day and I gave up I got give up I
got up and I talked and went on for
about an hour
I developed the world's most subtle
measure of prejudice i sat down and you
know sometimes things go just right and
I felt like this was just a tour de
force and you know my fellow students
were right on and then it was a long
rectangular table and I was at one end
and herb was at the other end
his head was down on his hands and and
as I sat down he lifted up his head and
he looked at me and he said you have no
idea what you're talking about
that's a quote and then he said you
think a bigot thinks he's a bigot
you think that a bigot strongest
motivation is to hide his bigotry from
you a bigot does not think that he's a
bigot a bigot knows that what he thinks
is what every reasonable person thinks
and knows and since you're a reasonable
person he knows you think it too and
that is why bigotry has power well herb
was right yeah there are parts of this
social world where people behave as
though they're you know dominant motive
or are said to behave as though they're
dominant motive is to present a socially
desirable image of themselves and
suppress any expression of dislike
ridges thing for blocks not not in the
world as it is and not not in an
interview when it's done as an interview
should be done when you've won the
confidence of your respondent when we
started the very first study that I did
with Tom Piazza scar of race we made up
a list of the most loathsome five things
that somebody could say about blacks and
and then as we were going over the
instrument with the interviewers they
said we won't do that we won't ask that
because there were little
and it was at the Survey Research Center
at Berkeley and we sat down and and said
we think that there are a lot of people
out there that believe this is
reasonable and we can't show that that's
true unless you give them an opportunity
to say these things
they're vile but there's a whole
research literature out there that says
that the responses are contained by this
social desirability bias and we think
that that's off the mark
anyway they did it
and and and and and each of those items
was endorsed by somewhere between 25%
and 40% of the sample which was a sample
of the San Francisco Oakland Bay Area
that is uncommonly
liberal and commonly a fluent uncommonly
well-educated and every study since
whatever it's been about I've had a
measured prejudice just to get one more
opportunity to demonstrate that there is
no shortage of folks that are willing to
say nasty things but I mean the
asymmetry between the willingness to
understand that there's prejudice and
that just got sense of ill ease at the
idea of accepting that there are others
that are motivated by goodwill that's
just done that's just deep in our
intellectual culture and I think has I
think that if you don't underst if one
does not understand that there has been
and is a struggle over race between
those who are intolerant
and mean-spirited and punitive and those
who are are more generous and empathetic
in their capacity to to feel for others
to respect others not merely to pity
them I think if you don't understand
that you don't understand the meaning of
the American contemporary American
experience there is a struggle there is
a conflict and that is what mere dog got
right
demographic changes happened the rise of
places like for example yeah which is
progressive politics but also the place
is within a very deeply segregated City
where there are not a lot of contact
so you have give me an example of what
you have mind you you've stated the
problem terms and nouns okay so I'm I'm
just a behaviorist okay so give me an
example of of a situation that you that
evokes what you have in mind when you
speak
here's the social I'll give you social
science start and then a political end
the social science start is the contact
theory that was introduced by Gordon
Allport who was then a faculty member at
Yale's rival very distinguished social
psychologist and the motivating
assumption was that as people interacted
with each other we would know and learn
about each other as individuals and that
would break down these group stereotypes
and there's been about sixty two and a
half years worth of research trying to
find conditions under which that's true
and and it just doesn't seem to have a
lot of power people keep adding
conditions so I became you know if you
have contact but its contacts among
equals okay not just contacts among
equals no contacts among equals who have
respect for each other and so on and and
some really wonderful work was done
especially on children Eliot arenson
jigsaw puzzle that inducing interaction
among school children so that they came
to behave as a group and so far as
there's a reliable finding it's at the
aggregate level which is that at the
aggregate level increased contract
contact is associated with increased
distance between groups okay so so
that's the now I want to argue exactly
against that for somebody who's of my
age what is most striking about the
political vocabulary of race in America
is how one word was written right out of
the dictionary and that word was
integration that was an idea that had
enormous moral force but I don't think
that I don't think that it's appeared in
an address by a university president
other than one occasion I'm aware of for
40 years we went in another direction
rather than integration being the idea
we got into the idea that actually there
was some degree of institutionalized
separation that was preferable and so we
had race themed houses and so if it's
it's the irony of the question that you
asked me in exactly the institutions
where you would think where one might
think
contact on the basis of of mere
familiarity would be a shared idea that
we are members of a common community and
that distinctions of a race or gender or
ethnicity or religion are incidental to
our membership in this community it's an
exactly this institution yeah but my
University just as much as yours which
has chosen otherwise and maybe maybe it
was the right choice
there is no counterfactual but it is the
choice that that distinguishes that
marks the difference between your
generation of mine
you